so on the standing C set drill number
one is the standing
Zen drill number two is the one we've
been doing okay this is like drill one
2.5 okay so he's going to do drill two
but I'm doing drill two at the same time
so he's on he's ground vectoring the
young aspect on the back mid fooot and
I'm ground vectoring on the back mid
foot too we were both organized okay I'm
now going to shift from the back midfoot
to the front
midfoot he maintains organization the
same way he is right now he maintains
that exact organization and lets
himself be moved by that organization
okay for
me as I do it there they were both on
the
midfoot I don't want to now bring my arm
into it you see you see how I did that
I'm cocking my
arm then I'm going to do the
projection no just like the seated drill
we did my arm does not move my elbow
doesn't change its
relationship same thing here I keep it
and I just move it
I'm going to have to open my hand of
course don't hold him and he goes and it
starts to pull you that would be weird
okay watch also your radical hip
turn back
foot front
foot back
foot front foot okay don't come in and
out don't come in to go out just hold
shift let go hold shift let go my hands
aren't doing anything okay try it
again and
grounding he's
pushing and
grounding likewise
I'm
grounding so if you pushed into me just
does the
same okay got it so when you're doing
this
drill you're on the back foot mid foot
is Cress
down when you go to the front
foot and I'm doing that ever so slowly
that foot is still on the ground
firmly the front foot is on the ground
firmly on the back foot
firmly when I shift my weight
don't want to take it off
there if you obey the the yin and
yangong of the knee
Bend
this is KNE to toes that's yang this is
ankle
straight if I move to Yang on
this it doesn't ever pull me off the
other
foot careful you're not here you pass
your toe Line This is not good for your
knees it's not marginal I can't move
okay I'm very susceptible to being
pulled as well so that would if you come
off the back foot that's part of your
desire to throw him you see and
instead just do the
drill ground Vector on the back
foot ground Vector on on the front foot
that's
it
okay okay
TR now we're at drill three so he comes
in um round
move round
move Sean I'll tell you
now no
just
move okay
try Okay so that part where I let it
fall through me just like zazen just
like in the first drill so the second
drill here just like in the first drill
I'm letting it drop it's y aspect same
thing I Let It Drop okay and I'm going
to shorten the
movement of the weight shifting
okay don't go here here it's inside
you need a little shift it's fine if you
need to go back to the uh last drill is
fine
but comes
in okay I have to train in a cultivation
field and that means that the stress
level cannot be to such a degree that I
start to lose all chances of acquiring
the skill okay
um what's happening in this drill as as
you he he's press seeing that young ASPC
is going in it's going to hit the ground
and I let it come back out and that's
what moves moves him okay so why well
when I'm here and I'm shift my weight I
am out Ying his Yong when I shift his
weight my weight and say he's displaced
on this one when he's still feeding y
that Yong comes back and does the same
thing it over yongs his Yong and he gets
back okay if he comes in very fast
whatever that y value is let's say it's
X that's how fast he goes back out okay
if he comes in very soft so let's say x
-1 and it's a small movement that he
feels only do you see that but he can
keep the shape he comes in quick and and
it's going to cause more of a jerking in
him okay got got that so don't come in
so fast that you're here and you're whoa
okay no no no let's keep what we're
trying to do I'm trying to make UK still
train in the drill so Yang aspect comes
in I let it come in and I let it descend
okay if you're finding oh I'm getting
jacked up just come in a little smoother
okay try